Hello, everyone, and welcome
to CME 296, Diffusion
and Large Vision Models.
My name is Afshine
and I'm going to be
teaching this class with
Shervine who's in the back.
So before we start.
I'm just going to
introduce ourselves.
So Shervine and I
are twin brothers
and we have very
similar backgrounds.
So we both went to a school in
France called Centrale Paris.
And then we came here to
the US to do grad school.
So on my end, I went to
MIT, and then Shervin
went to the ICME
Department at Stanford.
And then after that, we've
had pretty similar backgrounds
in the industry.
So we both went to Uber first,
and then we went to Google,
and now we're both at Netflix.
And the reason why we're
so excited to be teaching
this class is because back
in the day, 10 years ago,
when we started in
the field, we actually
had our first project be
a computer vision project.
And it's been crazy
the amount of progress
that we've seen in the field.
So this is the kind of images
that we were able to generate.
So it's back in 2014.
So it was mostly low resolution
black and white pictures.
So for instance, here there
some digits or human faces.
And as you all
know, nowadays we're
able to generate high
resolution colored images.
So for instance those ones
that I generated with ChatGPT.
And the goal of this
class is to understand
how this image
generation models work
and what makes
them work so well.
So in particular, this
class has two main goals.
So the first goal is to
understand the paradigms
behind how we can
generate these images.
And the second one
is to understand
how the underlying models
are trained and evaluated.
So in case you're
here in this room
and still wondering if
this class is good for you,
I would say that
this class is good
if you have, in general, an
interest in understanding how
image generation models work.
And in particular,
if this is something
that you wanted to
do as a career goal,
if you want to go in the
field of research to do
peer research
scientists to research
how to generate images
in a better way.
Or if you are
yourself interested,
to do that on your personal
time as a personal project,
or just if you're here
out of pure curiosity.
With that being said, I
want to give a warning.
So this class actually
has a pretty strong set
of prerequisites, and
I'm not going to hide it.
So this slide is just
there to enumerate
the kinds of
prerequisites that I
think are good to have just
so that you're not surprised.
So first of all, in case
you have some background
in linear algebra,
for instance, if you
know what a vector
is, what a matrix is,
how you do operations,
what is the gradient, what
is the divergence of a vector
field, that would be great.
If you don't everything,
that's OK too.
So in this class, we will not
assume that you know everything,
but if you have at
least some foundation,
it's quite important to have it.
So linear algebra is one.
Second one that's quite
important is probability theory.
So in particular Bayes'
rule, conditional marginal
probabilities.
What is an expectation?
What is the covariance
matrix, and what
is the Gaussian distribution?
Again, if you don't everything
it's fine, but at least
most of it or at least
if you've heard of it.
Then you have
differential equations.
So here we'll see how we
can use ODEs and SDEs.
So ordinary
differential equations
and stochastic differential
equations and how they matter,
and how we solve them.
And then last but not least,
there's some basics of ML.
So if you know how you train
a model, just in general using
a neural network, how you do
training, how you do inference,
that would be great.
But again, we will try
to review these concepts
in a non-exhaustive way
in an intuitive way.
But yeah, just knowing those,
I think, would be great.
So that's one Warning.
The second thing that I
will say is that this field
is very technical in general.
So if you read a computer
vision image generation paper,
you will see that there are
formulas all over the place.
So the goal of
this class will not
be to go into all
of these details.
So we will try to strike a
balance between not shying away
from the math, just
understanding what
are the important formulas,
but also at the same time,
just understand
why they're there.
So we'll try to make a
big emphasis on intuition.
All good so far?
OK, great.
So just moving on
to some logistics.
So we'll have this class every
Friday from 3:30 to 5:20 in this
class.
And just again logistics.
So it's a two unit class.
You can take it either as a
letter or credit non-credit.
So as you can see
with the setup,
the lectures are recorded.
We'll try to post the
videos by Saturday evening.
So for you watching remotely,
if you don't come to class,
it's all good.
We'll be just
publishing the videos
within a day of it happening.
And then in terms of the exams.
This class has no homework,
but we have two exams.
One is the midterm and the
other one is the final.
And here, it's the kind of exam
that you may or may not like,
but it is a pen and
paper kind of exam.
Meaning the lectures
that we will do
will be about concepts that
will be covered in the exam.
And the important thing is to
not know all the details, again,
just the general formulas
and mainly the intuition
as to why they're there.
So in case, it's a
little bit vague for you,
we have a similar class
that we do for LLMs.
I'm not sure if
you've heard CME 295.
So the format of the
exams is very similar.
So in case you're interested,
we put just a link
to one kind of exam
that you can expect.
Of course, it will not
be the same questions
because it's also
different topics,
but it will give
you a good idea.
Any questions on the exams?
Super clear?
Yeah I know it's
the first lecture,
and I'm talking
about exams already.
So yeah, don't worry.
It's four weeks away
and we have time.
And yeah, it's a fun
class, I promise.
Cool.
In terms of the material,
we have a class website,
and on that website we'll
be publishing the slides
and the recordings as well.
So just so that you have a way
to get the slides in advance
for annotation purposes,
one thing we will do
is to publish the slides
the day before the lecture,
so Thursday evening.
So you can get the slides
and make some annotations.
And if you saw, there is a tab
also top right cheat sheets.
We also published a condensed
four page cheat sheet
on the content of this class.
So it gathers all the main
formulas and concepts.
So our goal is--
if you look at it today, if you
don't understand parts of it,
our goal is by the
end of this class
to have everything
be very clear.
So if we achieve that
goal, I think that's great.
Cool.
OK.
So last thing.
So for any announcements, we'll
be posting them on Canvas.
And then we have a forum
for class discussions on Ed.
And of course, feel
free to reach out to us.
So there is the addresses
here on the slides,
if you need anything.
Cool.
I think these are
all the logistics.
Is there any questions so far
on just how the class works?
Yeah.
So the question-- so
I'm going to also repeat
the question for people at home.
So how long is the
midterm and the exam?
It's one hour and 30 minutes.
OK, cool.
I think we're all good then.
Great.
So let's get started.
So I just want to call out that
in the slides of this class what
we will do is to explain the
concepts in the main part,
but we will always
put a reference
to the paper that talks more in
depth about what we're talking
about, just because we
only have, I believe,
eight lectures of two hours, so
we have nowhere near covering
everything in detail.
So yeah, feel free
to look at them.
They will not be required
to know for the exam,
it's just for your
own reference.
OK, an important note.
So I mentioned that
the papers in the field
are crazy in terms of
technicality and math formulas,
the same goes for conventions.
So you will see that
from paper to paper,
things are noted differently,
and it can be very confusing.
So for instance, you will see
there is a time t that sometimes
is between 0 and 1,
sometimes it's between 0
and T, sometimes
it's in reverse,
sometimes a epsilon is not
a Z or X0 or X1, et cetera.
So in this class, what we will
try to do is three things.
First is we will always try
to rely on the most commonly
used notations, so that when you
go and refer to those papers,
you're not lost.
The second one is we will try
to stay consistent as much as
possible.
So if we take a notation,
we'll try to keep it
so that you're not confused.
And if we don't keep it, we'll
just make sure to call it out.
OK.
Great.
So as I mentioned this class
is all about understanding how
image generation models work.
So here you have a
typical setup where
you have let's say a
prompt where you specify
what you want to generate.
So here I want to generate
a Teddy bear reading a book.
And I put that in some model.
And then the model
generates an image.
So this is what
we want to cover.
But as easy as it seems,
it's actually quite complex.
There's a lot of things
moving pieces everywhere.
And I'm going to call
out the main moving
pieces that we'll cover.
So the first one
is if you suppose
that you have some model, how do
you go about generating images?
What is the process
of generating images?
So in the text
world is quite easy.
The most common paradigm
is you generate one token
at a time, because that's
also what people talk
and how people write,
so it's quite intuitive,
but in the image world,
it's not straightforward.
So we will focus lectures
1, 2, and 3 on this part.
And we will cover the
main ways of doing it,
which are the most
commonly used today, which
are diffusion, score
matching, and flow matching.
Then we will look at how we can
condition our model to generate
these images to start with.
So we'll cover
that in lecture 4.
So in some sense we
want to guide the model
to generate something, and
this is what we will cover.
We'll also cover how to
represent images in a space that
quote unquote, "makes sense."
So lecture 5 is going to be
about the model architecture.
So we'll take a look
at the backbones that
are most commonly used today.
So back in the day you
may have heard of u-net
as being something
that was used.
But there's currently a
convergence of architectures
more towards transformer
based architectures,
such as the
diffusion transformer
and variants such as
the multimodal diffusion
transformer, and we will
take a look at those there.
Then lecture 6 will
be around knowing
how to train those models.
So in particular, how
do you have your model
understand how to
generate images
and any post-training approaches
that you may also need.
There's also something that
is quite important, especially
in the industry, which
is you have your model,
but you want to run
it quicker because you
have some constraints
in your setup
so we will see also
distillation techniques.
So this will be in lecture 6.
And finally lecture 7 will
be about evaluating images.
Because if you
look at an image--
I'm not sure about you,
but it's not super obvious
how you would define an image
as being great or not great.
So you will see that the
field is full of acronyms
when it comes to metrics.
And each of those is there
actually for a reason
and we'll try to see that.
And then the second
thing that we will see
is this emergence
of multi-modal LLMs
that also understand
images that can also
help us to evaluate them.
So this will be for lecture 7.
And today as mentioned, we
will start with the generation
paradigm one.
And in particular, we
will look at diffusion.
So who has heard of diffusion.
Yeah, OK so everyone.
So we will see beyond the
general intuition of roughly
how that works.
We'll see exactly
how this was defined
and what is making this
objective be tractable
in practice.
So one thing that
I want to call out
is in the first
three lectures, we
will assume that there
is nothing as input.
So we have some
distribution of data
that we use as training sets.
And what we want is to generate
images that are like them.
So in mathematical
terms, we want
to have a model that is able
to sample an observation
from the data distribution.
So in a sense we'll only focus
on unconditioned generations
for the first three
lectures including this one.
Cool.
So speaking of
data distribution.
So let's suppose we
have a set of images.
So here a long running
example will be Teddy Bears.
So here let's say we have
a collection of Teddy
Bears as training images.
Our goal is to understand
a way to sample
an observation from that data
distribution that is new.
So what we want to do is to be
able to generate an image that
is in that data distribution.
So here for instance giraffe.
And again, just emphasizing
that this is unconditioned.
We're not putting
anything as input.
We just want to
generate a sample that
is following that distribution.
So how do we do this?
So you will see that most if
not all methods out there,
they all have
something in common.
They all start their image
generation process from noise.
So they start from
noise, and then
they refine the image
to be the final image.
So I want to just spend some
time on why that is the case.
So we'll define what
noise means, by the way
because you will
see the term noise
and then you will see
this grayish image.
So you will see that this
noise is actually something
that you can sample from
an easy distribution,
the Gaussian distribution,
spoiler alert.
So the first reason why it is
something that we want to do
is because it is easy
to sample from noise.
It is easy to have some noise.
The second thing is noise has
some randomness that allows you
to generate different images.
So even if let's say
you have a condition,
if you start from noise
that is different,
let's say from
another generation,
you will be able to end up
with a different end image
just because the starting
point is different.
So the second reason it
introduces some randomness.
And then the third one
is, as I mentioned,
noise is basically equal
to a Gaussian distribution,
and that distribution
just happens
to have very nice properties.
So it simplifies
a lot of the math
and we will see a
little bit how that is
the case in the diffusion case.
Cool.
So intuitively does that
make sense, that noise
is a good starting point?
Yeah?
OK, cool.
And just to complete that
intuition, in the 3D world,
how sculptors go about
sculpting their sculptors,
they start with some rock.
And you can think of this
rock as having shapes
that are a little bit noisy.
It's not something
that you are defining.
It's something
that is just there.
And that will be different
from a rock to another.
So one analogy that
I like to think of
is this image generation
process is a little bit
if you were a sculptor and you
wanted to sculpture from rock.
So yeah, I will leave you with
that quote from Michelangelo
that I think also
reflects that pretty well.
Cool.
Yeah.
So when you say uniforms,
you mean the same thing?
Like let's say blank?
Yeah so the question
is, why do you
want to start from
noise, but not
from something
that is predefined,
let's say a black-- sorry
a white canvas, let's say.
So yeah, great question.
So you will see that
what makes the end--
so the generation
process sometimes
involves some randomness
in the generation process,
sometimes it does not.
The randomness is something that
occurs at the starting points.
So if you were to always
start your process
from the same starting point,
given that everything else does
not introduce some
amount of randomness,
you will always end up
at the same endpoint.
So in a sense, what you want
is to have some variation
introduced somewhere in
order to not always end up
at the same place.
So I'll give you an example.
This Teddy bear reading a book.
If you use a generation
paradigm that does not
have any stochasticity
in its process,
then if you always start
from the same point,
then you will always end
up at the same endpoint,
and that's probably not
something that you want just
for diversity purposes.
So that's the intuition.
Yeah, great question.
Cool.
OK.
So what we'll focus on for this
lecture is a landmark paper
that I will talk a lot in
depth, that's called DPM.
That was the first that
applying this diffusion paradigm
for images in a successful way.
So what we're going
to do is to go
through what makes this
approach work so well,
and the underlying mechanisms
that lead to the loss
function that we have.
So in particular, the
idea that we have here
is what we want is to
generate new images.
So what we do have is a
set of training images
and our goal is if we
were to start from noise,
how would we be able to
recover those images?
That's what we want to learn.
Because as I mentioned during
our generation process,
our strategy is to
start from noise
and end up with a clean image.
So here what we want to do is
to use those training set images
to learn that denoising process.
So in that regard, we
have two processes that
have a very particular name.
So the first one is called
the forward process that
amounts to taking an image
from your training set,
and you are actually
corrupting that image.
You're adding some noise.
So here you have
some process that you
define that goes from
some image xt minus 1,
and then produces an image
xt by adding some noise.
So again, this is a
process that you define.
So you know what Q is
in the forward process.
And what you want to do is
to start from that noise
distribution that is
so easy to sample,
and then go through
the reverse process
to actually denoise that
sample back to the clean space.
And so what you want
to learn is a model,
that is something we will
characterize with the parameters
theta--
what you want to learn is how
you would go from a noisy image
to a less noisy one.
So you may wonder, OK, so
you're talking about xts,
but we don't what is xt.
It's just a noisy image.
How do you go about
just representing images
in the first place?
So here we will just see one
way of representing images.
That is not the way people
usually go about it.
That's something that we'll
go more in depth in lecture 4,
but I just want to tell you
how you would try to represent
images in this framework.
So as you know, an image
is composed of pixels.
So you have a height
and you have a width.
So each pixel is
actually composed
of three values red,
green, and blue,
and this allows you to
cover a number of colors.
So based on that, you
can represent your image
as a function of
all the pixels that
are composing that image,
where each of these pixels
contains some value for
each of these colors.
So you can think of
each pixel as having
three values, one that
represents the amount of red,
the other one that represents
the amount of green,
and the other one that
represents the amount of blue.
So based on that, it is fair
to say that you can represent
images in a vectorial fashion.
So here the dimensionality
of the image in this example
would be equal to the
number of pixels times
the number of dimensions
you need to represent
in a pixel, which is 3.
So here you would
have n dimensions
where n is equal to
number of pixels times 3.
So this would be one way
to represent your images.
Of course, this is not
the most clever way
of representing images, and we
will see that more in lecture 4.
But what I want
you to remember is
when we talk about
images here, when
we say x0, xt and so on,
what we're talking about
is actually vectors.
And these vectors
are the ones that
are representing these images.
Make sense?
Cool.
So, speaking of vectors.
So I told you there is a
prerequisite on probability
theory, so I'm just going
to cover the basics here.
So you may know the common
distribution, that's
called the Gaussian
distribution,
normal distribution where you
have some random variable that
is drawn from a
distribution of mean mu
and then variance sigma squared.
Well, you can have the
same thing for vectors.
So I know all these papers
they assume you know that.
When you read, it's
not super clear,
so just want to emphasize.
You can also have random
variables that are vectors.
And in this case, you
will have a vector that
is drawn from a
distribution of some mean
and the mean is a vector
and then some variance,
which is actually represented
by a covariance matrix.
So don't worry if you don't
about the covariance matrix,
because most of the
time we actually
simplify the
covariance matrix to be
a variance times the identity.
And we call this
formulation actually--
so these are like
isotropic Gaussians.
Because what that means
is that the variation
of the data across all
directions is the same.
So most of the time, to
just simplify the math,
what we will assume is that
the covariance is actually
equal to sigma squared i, which
is the diagonal matrix which
you see here and not the super
complicated covariance matrix.
So by the way, do you remember
what covariance is roughly?
So maybe I can just recap.
So what is covariance?
So covariance is a
quantity that quantifies
how two random variables
vary in a linear way.
Of course, there is some
mathematical expression,
but this is like the
general intuition.
So speaking of
intuition, when we
say that a distribution is
isotropic, this is what we mean.
We mean that the variance is
the same across all directions.
So you can think of it as
some circle where the color
represents the density.
Yeah.
OK, cool.
And of course, what's
great about Gaussians
is you also have an
analytical expression that's
quite simple about the
probability density function.
So I'm just putting this here,
and it's easy to compute.
That's great.
So going back to
what we call noise.
So here we saw that images
can be represented by vectors.
So when we say we
sample from noise,
we will say here
that we actually
sample from a standard
normal distribution.
So we usually note that epsilon.
So epsilon will be drawn from a
normal distribution of mean 0.
So 0 is actually the
vector, the 0 vector.
And then the covariance will
actually be the identity matrix.
Yeah.
It's a great question.
So the question is
is the representation
continuous or discrete?
So we talked about pixel
values that were discrete 0, 1,
2 until 255.
But in practice, these are
actually scaled between,
let's say minus 1 and 1 or some
value that's more of a float.
So you can assume that these
are actually continuous.
But you can assume it's
actually continuous.
Yeah.
So there's always
some assumption.
And so here at
least when you say
there is no correlation
between pixels-- so here
we actually mean the noise.
So noise we actually
just sample at random.
So yeah, yeah.
It's not true for
actual images, though.
No, it's not true.
Yeah, yeah.
Great questions.
OK, cool.
I'm just looking at the time and
I know we have a lot of content,
so I'll just go a
little bit faster.
Just want to know if
the pace so far is good.
Yeah.
OK.
I don't want to
lose you because I
think this is the first lecture
that is maybe the most difficult
in terms of math.
So it's just kind of sad that
this is the first lecture.
But yeah, let's continue.
So as I mentioned, what we want
to do is to take clean images
and to corrupt them.
So what we do is we take some
image that maybe we have noised
and we add some noise.
And we actually add
these quantities
in a weighted fashion.
And these weights are
actually defined by us.
So if you remember, when we
talked about queue, the process
that we defined for
the forward process,
is actually something
that we define.
So this is how we
know it's images.
So we take an image.
We take some noise
from a distribution,
from the normal
distribution and then
we do a weighted average with
some weights that we will see.
And speaking of
those, you will hear
of a recurring term across
all papers, noise schedule.
So the noise
schedule is actually
referring to the
coefficients here that you
use to multiply these values.
So it's a schedule
because at some point,
you may add maybe less noise
than some other points.
Yeah?
OK.
Great.
So let's go a little
bit more into the math.
So we start from x0.
And then the way
we go about adding
noise is we have our forward
process that we've defined
q which is actually
something we will draw
from a normal distribution.
So we can express the
quantity-- so q of xt,
so the noisier image compared
to the less noisy image
as a normal
distribution centered
on that less noisy image
with some coefficient
where you add some
noise, which is
something that is represented by
the covariance matrix beta ti.
Yeah.
So what that means--
I'm just going to
rewrite this in a very--
so it's just what that means.
So it's xt is equal to
1 minus beta xt minus 1
plus square root of
beta and some noise.
So this seemingly math
formula is just nothing else
than just you taking
your less noisy image,
weighting that by
some coefficient,
and then adding some noise
with some coefficient.
Now you may wonder why are
you using these coefficients?
So we will see later in
the class why we do that.
But you can see that the
variance of this whole thing
is preserved from
one step to another.
So you will see that this
way of noising images
is called variance
preserving, VP.
We'll see that more later on.
OK, cool.
So speaking of the
noise schedule.
So these beta t are
not typically uniform,
they're varying.
And the way they are
defined in the DDPM paper
is they're gradually increased.
As in you will start
from your clean image,
and you will just add
a little bit of noise,
and then maybe a little bit
more, and again and again.
And then at the end, you
will have much bigger noise.
And the reason
why people do that
is because when you're close to
the clean image, what you care
about is to learn
those little details,
but when you're closer to
the noise, what you care more
about learning is the
general shape of the image.
So this noise
schedule is actually
quite important in
our ability to learn
and it's just one
way of doing things.
Yeah.
And as you can tell,
it's a between 0 and 1,
well, because otherwise you
would have a negative value
in the square root.
Cool.
Moving on.
So if you define your
process like this
then it turns out you
don't need to noise
your images in a sequential way
in order to get the number t1.
You can actually go directly
from your clean image
to the step number t.
Do you see how
you would do that?
Maybe it's not super
obvious, but I told you
that Gaussians had
very nice properties.
So here, epsilon,
the noise is drawn
from a Gaussian distribution.
So if you were to
rewrite-- so first of all,
I will just define
alpha t, which
is just equal to 1 minus beta
t is just a reparametrization.
So here it will be
1 minus alpha t.
So here what we're
saying is xt minus 1
we can also use the
same formula, which
will be equal to square root
of alpha t minus 1 xt minus 2
plus square root of 1
minus alpha t minus 1
and the other Gaussian.
So these noise are independent.
So if you were to express
xt as a function of xt
minus 2 and the epsilons,
what would you do?
So here I'm just
going to expand xt.
So here I'm just in parentheses.
So it's equal to alpha t
square root of alpha t.
So I'm directly going to
multiply this quantity
by the one that we have here.
So it's square root of
alpha t times square root
of alpha t minus 1 xt minus 2
plus square root of alpha t.
Square root of 1
minus alpha t minus 1.
T minus 1 plus.
So by the way, I'm
just doing some math.
Very basic math.
Plus square root of 1
minus alpha t epsilon t.
So far so good?
So here we have our first term.
No problem.
Then what we have is a weighted
sum of random variables
drawn from a Gaussian
distribution.
So I told you that these
Gaussian distributions
had very nice properties.
So it turns out that if you
have two random variables that
are independent and drawn
from a Gaussian distribution,
so you can really
have this as being
equal to the standard
deviation of this quantity
times a random variable that
is also drawn from a Gaussian
distribution.
So how do you add this variance?
So you have the
variance of everything
that is equal to the variance
of 1 plus the variance of other.
So here in terms of
how that looks like--
so here, you will
have the variance
that will be equal to alpha t.
So it's basically this
squared plus this squared.
So it's alpha t1 minus--
1 minus alpha t minus
1 plus 1 minus alpha t
which is equal to--
so this one goes away.
And then you have 1 minus
alpha t, alpha t minus 1.
So what does that mean?
That means that xt is equal to
square roots of alpha t alpha t
minus 1.
So I'm just like
copying what is above.
Xt minus 2.
Plus the standard
deviation of this one,
which is square
root of the variance
times a random
variable that is drawn
from the normal distribution.
And this sketch of a
proof is just a way for us
to prove that you can actually
cascade these things up to 0.
And therefore you can
have an expression
of the noisy image at
step t as a function
of the clean image at step 0.
And this can be expressed
as a function of alpha bar,
where alpha bar is equal to
the product of the alpha I's.
So here alpha t alpha t
minus 1 is just the start.
But if you continue it's just
the product of all the alpha
t's.
Does that make sense?
So what I just wrote on the
board is just a way for you
to be convinced that what
I'm saying is making sense.
So you can express xt
as a function of x0
by just using alpha t bar
instead of this beta t.
Cool.
So yeah.
So the derivation
you use the fact
that the variance of the
sum of independent Gaussians
is just the sum of the
respective variances.
And by the way, there's
many derivations
we can do in this class, the
problem is we do not have time.
So here is the
first one, which is
why I wrote on the blackboard.
But if we do not have
time, we will always
have a little message at the
bottom of the slide that just
tells you what the trick is.
And you can safely
assume that if we
don't derive this
thing in class,
it will not be asked
during the exams.
OK.
Cool.
Moving on.
So now what we have done is just
defined our forward process,
and we just also
derived a convenient way
to noise our image from step
0 to step T without going
through all the steps.
So what we will do now is
to see how we can actually
go about determining the process
that denoisers that forest
process.
So what we want to
is how can we go
about seeing what p theta
of xt minus 1 given xt is.
So as I mentioned, what we want
to do is to learn p of theta.
So in case you have
some experience in ML,
you will see that a
common trick that people
do is given some training
data what they want to do
is to maximize the
probability of your model
seeing the training
data maximized.
They want to maximize such
a probability with respect
to theta.
So they want to find the
parameters theta that
maximize the probability of your
model of seeing your training
data.
So in this case training data
is just our training images.
So it's clean images.
And then our model
here is something
that has p theta in it.
So it's the probability of
an image happening that we
will see how we can condition.
And what we want to do is to
find the parameters theta that
do that.
So you will see that whenever
you talk about probabilities,
you will always or
most of the time
talk about log probabilities.
One because the
logarithm function
has pretty nice properties.
And then the second
reason is that it's just
computationally more stable,
because probabilities
are between 0 and 1.
So if you have very,
very small values of p,
then it can be a
little bit unstable.
So before we
determine that, I just
wanted to go through some
refresher of a concept
in probabilities that is the
joint probability distribution.
So here if you suppose that you
have two random variables that
are drawn from
two distributions,
let's say it's x1 and x2, the
random variables, then you
can compute the joint
probability distribution,
by taking the probability
density of x1,
and multiplying that by
the conditional probability
of x2 given x1.
So this is just by
definition, it's
the probability chain of rule.
And in practice, when you have a
joint probability distribution,
one way you can represent
that is through a heat map.
So here you have, let's
say, your two axes.
One is representing
the one along x1
and the other one along x2.
And then here the
color that you see here
is the density value of this
joint probability distribution.
So this is for
instance 1 square.
And the way you
would go about doing
this for the conditional
probabilities
you would actually just
look at one column.
And here the probability
of x2 given x1
would be the proportion of the
value of the joint probability
distribution in that square
over the sum of all the squares
for that given value x1.
So far I'm just
recapping what we
know about joint
probability distributions
and conditional probabilities.
So what I want to tell
you is a notion of what
we call marginalization,
which is if you want to obtain
the probability of just
one random variable,
then what you can do is to
sum the joint probability
of that random variable and
a second random variable,
and you can sum it along
that second variable.
And this is called
marginalization.
Do you all know-- have you all
heard what marginalization is?
Yeah?
OK, cool.
So what I'm saying is a
little bit obvious then.
So in this figure so the
way you would obtain p of x1
is you sum all the squares
relative to x1 again and again
and again and you can
reconstitute your probability
distribution.
So that's the way
you would see this
from a graphical perspective.
And so we saw that when we
only have two random variables,
but you can very well do that
when we have T random variables.
And so here we have the
probability chain rule
like at the top of the slide.
So you have p of
x1 times p of x2,
given x1 et cetera times p of
xt given x1 up to xt minus 1.
So this is just extending
that to a dimension of t.
And one notation that you
will see very often in papers
is this one.
So the joint probability
distribution of T variables
is usually denoted p of x1t.
So just to save space.
And the reason why I'm
presenting these slides
is just to tell you that
this is the main notation
that people use and
this is what it means.
Cool.
And with that
simplified notation,
you can just rewrite the
formulas from before as follows.
So now if we were to
come back to the problem
that we had around finding
parameters theta that
maximize the probability of our
models seeing the training data.
Here, what we want to do
is to express p theta of x0
or log of p theta of x0.
So we've seen a few slides
ago that the way we obtain x0
is sampling from a noise
distribution at time t.
And then going step by step
from big t to big t minus 1,
et cetera, up until 0.
So in order to compute this
quantity, one idea for you
could be to take the joint
probability distribution
over all the time
steps and then sum
across all these different
quantities except x0.
A.K.A. you can just
marginalize, right?
So one idea is to say that
the logarithm of p theta of x0
is the logarithm of the
integral of p theta of x0
and then x1 up to t.
D of x1 to t.
So this is just the
definition of marginalizing.
So the problem with
this formulation is that
it's actually something we
cannot compute because here
we're saying let's marginalize--
let's sum across all possible
trajectories from
noise to clean image.
So the problem is
there are many of them.
And these x's we saw
that these are vectors,
and they can be pretty big.
So long story short, is this is
in practice something that we
cannot compute.
Which is the reason why we have
a recipe that we will go through
in the next 33
minutes as to how we
can compute that using
the forward process
that we have defined.
So in the interest
of time, I'm going
to skip some blackboard
derivation, which is fine.
I'm just going to
give you the trick.
If time permits we
can do a few ones.
But the important
thing for you is
to just understand the
high-level strategy
around obtaining the loss that
will be used to train our model.
Sounds good?
Cool.
So let's start with
the first step.
So I told you that
this expression
is something that is actually
not something we can compute
because it's just intractable.
So a common trick
that people use
is to find something
that is easy to compute
that is not necessarily
the quantity of interest,
but maybe a bound that is
close to what you want.
So here what you want is to
maximize that expression.
So if you were to
maximize something
that you know is lower than
that, so a lower bound,
then it would also allow you to
gain some confidence that you're
maximizing the right thing.
So there is a very scary
formula on the slides
which we'll go through right
now, which is the elbo.
Have you heard of the
ELBO before this class?
Yeah.
ELBO stands for
evidence lower bound.
And what that means
is it's an expression
of a quantity that is a
lower bound of the quantity
that we care about.
And actually, this
is quite important,
so I think I will derive it.
So while I'm cleaning
the blackboards,
I just want to tell you
about what the trick is.
The trick is that we
have our forward process
that we have defined, so q.
And what we want to do is to
have q be in some way something
that we appear.
Like in our equation, we
want to involve q in some way
because what Q is.
Q is this forward
process that we
have defined when we do the
noise schedule this beta t alpha
t, we know that.
So what we want to do is to
express that as a function of q.
So we go back with the
log of p theta of x0,
which we said we tried to
marginalize across x1 to xt.
So I'm just going to
rewrite what we had above.
And then what I'm going
to do, as I mentioned,
is have q appear.
So very common trick.
What I'm going to
do is to multiply
the numerator and the
denominator by that quantity.
So I'm going to do
this one times q of--
So given a clean image,
what is the trajectory
that is given by q?
So it's q of x1 to xt
given your clean image.
OK.
Everyone is following me so far?
Just a very regular trick.
So OK.
So where do we go from there?
So I'm just going to
remove the log for now.
So this is true.
So this expression
is actually nothing
else than the expectation
of this quantity
because this is as if you
were sampling x1 through T
from this distribution.
So it's as if you
were writing this.
were saying it's
the expectation of this ratio,
which is p theta of x0 to t over
q of x1 to t, given
x0, where x1 through t
is something that you draw from
q of x1 through t given x0.
OK I hope-- so don't
worry by the way.
It's all going to
be in the recording.
It's going to be much clearer in
case you cannot see very clear
what I'm writing, but what I'm
writing is the expectation.
This quantity is the
expectation of the ratio
between p theta of
x0 to t over q of x1
through T, given
x0 by sampling x1
through t-- so the
trajectory through t
via the forward process that
we know, which is given by x1
through t given x0.
So where do we go from here?
So it turns out that there
is a very common trick--
very common trick
out there that's
called the Jensen
inequality where
if you have a convex
or concave function,
you have some very nice
property about something
we're going to see.
And in particular, in this
case, log is a concave function.
So if you have the log
of some expectation,
it's actually something
that is greater
or equal than the
expectation of the log.
I'm not going to write
this whole thing,
but you know what I mean.
So this is Jensen's inequality.
Jensen.
And this is exactly
what we get here.
So one way we
progressed is instead
of summing through all
possible trajectories,
now what we're doing
is we're actually
sampling from
trajectories that were
drawing from the forward
process, which we know.
And now you're wondering
why in the slide
are we sampling x0
through T. But here I
said x1 through t sample
from q of x1 through t
given x0 is because if
you take the expectation
of this whole
thing, then you take
the expectation over
x0 of expectation of x1
through t times that.
So you use the chain
rule of probability
that we saw right before.
And it's exactly the same.
Just one expectation of sampling
the whole joint probability
distribution through
this q x0 through t.
Does this make sense?
So you may see this formula
and wonder, OK, it's
still super complicated,
how can I compute that.
Well, right now, you do not
know that it is tractable.
I'm just telling you.
But the intuition
here is we're actually
not summing through all
possible trajectories.
We're actually summing
through trajectories
that we're sampling from
the forward process.
Yeah?
So now it's step number one.
Step number 2 is
proving or showing
that this is something
that you can compute.
But before that,
I'm going to, again,
give you some refresher of
a very important concept
that is the KL divergence.
Who has heard of KL divergence?
Yeah, everyone?
I'm just going to remind
you what KL divergence is.
So if you take two
probability distributions--
so let's say p and q--
and you want to measure how
far apart they are, then
there is some operator that is
here, the KL divergence, which
quantifies how far
apart they are.
And the way they do
that is by taking--
maybe it's something
I treat on the slide.
So I'm just going
to continue their.
So by taking the sum of the log
of the ratio between these two
probabilities weighted by the
probability distribution p.
So in the discrete world,
it's going to be like this.
But we're going to be mostly
in the continuous world.
And in the continuous
world, the KL divergence
is this, but in integral form.
And it's the same
as saying you take
the expectation of the
logarithm of the ratio
if you were to assume that
x is sampled through p.
Yeah?
OK.
So given that, we can prove
that the ELBO term that we saw--
so you know this
lower bounds here,
it can actually be
expressed with terms--
so some terms that we
actually don't really care
and we're just going to
ignore-- plus a term here,
which is the KL divergence of q
of xt minus 1 given xt and x0.
So it's the first distribution.
And the second
distribution is actually
the probability of having
the less noisy image
xt minus 1 given xt, which is
the thing that we want to learn.
So we don't have
time to derive this,
but it's actually not that
complicated of a derivation.
You would just take
this expectation of log,
and then you would do some
manipulation here and there,
and you can basically pop up
the KL divergence operator
through that.
So I think this one, I
will need you to trust me
that this is equal to this.
So why are we happy?
The reason why we're
happy is because we
have a clear comparison between
two probability distributions,
one that we care about, and
another one that is potentially
something that is tractable.
And so just to tell you
what q of xt minus 1 given
xt and x0 means, so it means
that if I were to give you
a noisy image and a clean image,
my question for you would be,
what would be the
less noisy image
if I were to give you this tool.
So the good thing is that at
training time, you know x0.
So you can compute
this quantity.
So a natural step
for us is now to show
that this quantity that I
mentioned is indeed tractable.
So we're going to see what q of
xt minus 1 given xt and x0 is.
So again, it is the
fact of wondering
what is the distribution
of the less noisy image
if I were to not only
give you the more noisy
image, but also the clean
image, which is actually
a lot of information.
So you may remember, or you
may have heard of Bayes' rule.
And it is something that we will
use, a trick we will use here.
So using the notations
that you would commonly
see and read and
hear out there, it's
the fact of saying
that the posterior is
equal to the likelihood
times the prior
over the marginal likelihood.
So in this case, it's P
of A given B equal to P
of B given A times
P of A over P of B.
And so knowing that, it's
actually quite easy to show
that this thing is tractable.
So this is probably
something we will derive.
So here, so what we want is q
of xt minus 1 given xt and x0.
So if we were to use
Bayes' rule with q
of the conditional
probability based on x0 if you
have this formula--
so if we were to write
this by considering
p equal to q conditional
on x0, what we would do
is-- so what I'm doing is
just applying Bayes' rule.
So it's equal to
q of xt given xt
minus 1 x0 times q of xt minus
1 x0 over q of xt given x0.
You all agree?
I'm just doing Bayes' rule.
So it's something that I
have not told you so far.
But q has a very
special property.
Q is Markovian.
So what does that mean?
It means that q of xt,
given everything before--
let's say before-- is
actually equal to q
of xt given xt minus 1.
In other words, you only need
to know about the previous step
to know the current step.
So it's called a Markov process.
So this simplifies to q
of xt given xt minus 1.
And then we saw before
that q of xt minus 1 given
x0 and q of xt given x0 are
quantities that are tractable.
They are this
normal distribution.
Do you remember this
derivation I made with,
OK, let's replace xt minus 1
as a function of xt minus 2
until getting x0?
Do you remember?
So these two quantities,
they are tractable.
This is tractable,
this is tractable.
Actually, this one,
we don't really
care because we want to compute
q of xt minus 1 given xt and x0.
So here, we're only
varying xt minus 1,
but q of xt given x0
everything is fixed.
So you can interpret
that as a constant.
And so what we end up with--
I cannot do that.
Yeah.
Are you referring to this one?
The left hand side.
So here's the thing--
in this derivation, the quantity
that we actually care about
is q of xt minus 1
just given xt and x0.
So this is just because of
the derivation of the elbow,
the fact that we end up here.
And that's just the
fact that we just
are interested in what is
the distribution of the less
noisy data if we what
the noisier one is
and the clean image is.
That's the thing
that we care about.
And so here, what I want to
say is that this is something--
so x of t minus 1,
knowing xt and x0,
is proportional of q of xt,
given xt minus 1, times q of xt
minus 1 given x0.
This is Gaussian.
The product of probabilities
of Gaussian is a Gaussian.
I'm not going to
derive everything,
but please trust
me that the form
of q of xt minus
1 given xt and x0
is a normal distribution
in particular
with the mean of this formula.
I'm not going to
read it, but it's
a function of the noisy image
and then the sampled noise
that allows you to
go from x0 to xt.
So this distribution is
exact, meaning we have not
approximated anything.
And this is something that
we know because we have
defined our forward process.
And here, we're
cheating a little bit
because we're saying, what is
the less noisy distribution if I
give you the more noisy one,
but also the clean image.
So it's a little bit of cheating
because at training time,
we know what x0 is.
Of course, at inference
time, we do not.
So know one term.
The second term is this p
theta of xt minus 1 given xt.
Now let's show that
it is tractable.
Well, that one is going
to be easy because we
can choose what p theta is.
And turns out that
it's very fair for us
to assume that it
is also a Gaussian
just because the forward
process of xt minus 1 given xt
is also approximately
a Gaussian.
So justification for that is a
little bit more into the weeds.
So I'm not going
to go into that.
But all of that to
say that in this part,
we're just making the assumption
that what we want to learn
is a Gaussian.
So what we end up with
is a KL divergence
of a Gaussian with a Gaussian.
And I'm not sure
if you remember,
but early in the
lecture, I told you
that we know the probability
density function of a Gaussian.
We have the explicit formula.
We do know.
So if you replace these into
the KL divergence formula, which
is this integral of log
of p over q and then p,
then it turns out you have a
lot of things that simplify.
And at the end of the
day, what you end up with
is just the distance between the
noise that you want to predict
and the noise that you sample
to go from the clean image
to the noise image.
Take the L2 distance of that.
Is everyone clear
with that transition?
So what we did was we
had that elbo elbow,
which was equal to this
KL divergence term.
And what we said
was, OK, looks good
because p theta is what
we want to compute.
And then this q thing is
something we have defined.
So let's try to see
if it's tractable.
And what we said
was, OK, let's see
if q is tractable, q of xt
minus 1 given xt and x0.
So we went into the math.
We did the Bayes' rule.
And then there is
this latter derivation
around actually determining
the mean and the variance
of that normal distribution
that I've not covered just
because it's just too much.
And it's OK to just assume
that if you do this at home,
you end up with a normal
distribution of this mean.
And then we also
showed that p theta
is something that is tractable.
And the way we have
shown that is just
by assuming that
it is a Gaussian.
So Gaussian of some mean
and then some variance.
And at the end of
the day, we end up
with a loss that is nothing
else than an L2 regression
on the noise that we have
added to our clean image
to obtain the noisy image.
Do you agree that that loss
is looking pretty good?
It's very tractable.
You just have to
regress your noise
on the noise from
the clean image
to the noisy image
as a training loss.
It's great.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you.
So the question is,
what is epsilon theta.
So I'm going to go
through each term.
So here, what is shown on
the slide is loss of DDMP.
So DDPM is this whole framework
of defining a forward process
in order to determine
how you want
to reverse the process, which
is why it's called LDPM.
And what is on the right
hand side of the equal sign
is an expectation over t that
you sample, which is the noise
level if you want, x0, which is
clean images in your training
set, and then epsilon is
random noise that you sample
from a normal distribution.
Sorry, standard
normal distribution,
which is basically a Gaussian of
mean 0 and variance the identity
matrix.
So what is in the expectation
is on the one side,
Epsilon theta, which is your
model predicting what noise
was added, and then
on the right side
is epsilon, which
is the actual noise
that you added from
the clean image
directly to the noisy image.
And what is in the parentheses?
So square root of alpha
t bar x0 plus square root
of 1 minus alpha t bar
epsilon-- this is equal to xt.
So it's the noisy image because
you can go from the clean image
and epsilon directly
to the noisy image
with using the identity
that we have seen.
So in other words, it is saying,
if I give you the noisy image,
please compute the
noise that was added
and compare that to the
actual noise that was added.
So one thing that
I will call out
is there are actually
two arguments.
You not only give the
model the noisy image,
but you're also giving it the
information of how noisy it is.
T. So here, t is
between 0 and big t.
So if T is more
towards 0, it means
you didn't add a lot of noise.
And if t is more
towards big T, it
means you've added
much more noise.
So it just allows
the model to know,
given this noisy
image, how noisy it is.
So it can calibrate how much
noise to predict to remove.
Does that make a bit more sense?
Perfect.
So yeah, but great question.
And we're actually going to
go through exactly what that
means in practice if we
want to train the model.
But before we do that, any
other questions on the loss?
Yeah.
So the question is this
loss represents the elbow.
So we are actually going
to see exactly how we
went from the first step to
this step in the next slide.
So I'm going to answer
a question right now.
So apart from this any
other questions on this?
We're good?
So I'm going to answer
your question now.
So do you remember
the strategy plan
we had with these four steps.
So we went from this maximum
likelihood estimation problem
that we wanted to perform.
And we said we
have a lower bound.
So that's where the
elbow comes then
from the elbow, which is a lower
bound of what we care about,
what we said was actually
expand the terms.
And we were like,
oh wow, we actually
have a KL divergence between
two things that seem tractable.
And then what we said
was, OK, so let's look
at that KL divergence term.
There are two parts to it.
One is q of xt minus
1 given xt and x0.
The other one is p theta
of xt minus 1 given xt.
We saw that these two
terms were tractable.
They were Gaussians.
And we knew what the mean
of these two Gaussians were.
And then what we said was
we have two Gaussians.
We know their probability
density functions.
We have a KL divergence of that.
Then we can actually compute
this whole thing analytically
and, as a result of that, end up
with a loss that's very simple.
Now there is something
that I simplified
that I've not told you yet,
but I'm going to tell you now.
When you simplify this scale
divergence, what you actually
get is the expectation
of this L2 regression
times some coefficients.
You can think of it as
the weight of the loss.
And this is something that
you as the person who's
training the model can choose.
Now, the authors of DDPM,
they try different ways.
They tried the actual thing.
They tried without by
having a coefficient of 1.
And they actually said, OK,
it's actually not that bad.
You can actually
take equal to 1,
but this is something that
you can actually choose.
And this is how you end up
to this last expression.
So let's see how we do
training and inference.
So we see the strategy.
So what you want to do
is to minimize that loss.
So what you do is you
sample the amount.
So first, the clean image
from your training set.
You sample your noise
and then the time step.
And in that way, you
constitute the noise image.
So you can go from clean
image with the amount of noise
up to the noised image.
What you do is you
take that noised image,
you take the noise level,
and then what you do
is you try to predict
the noise that
was added using your model,
which right now we don't know.
It's just a black box.
And you compute the loss and
you do your back propagation.
So that's the training.
And then the inference
is you sample your noise,
which is super easy to do.
And what you do is you go
step by step from noise
to less noise to less
noise to less noise,
up until arriving at t equals
0, which is clean image.
And here, what you do is
you use the expression
of p theta of xt minus
1 given xt, which
is something we
have derived, which
is a function of the noisy
image and the predicted noise
that you can remove.
And then you add some
noise on top of it
because let's remember that p
theta of xt minus 1 given xt
is a normal distribution.
So the noise here
just corresponds
to the standard deviation
of that distribution.
And when you do that
from big T to 0,
you then obtain
your clean image.
Cool.
I know this was a lot.
I know this is lecture 1.
I can tell you that this lecture
is probably the most difficult
of the eight first lectures.
So if you feel a little bit
like it's a lot to digest,
it's normal.
Hopefully we've tried to make
it a bit more digestible.
Luckily, there is a recording.
We have the notes,
we have everything.
I mean, hopefully, if we
don't, just let us know.
And with that, I'm going
to give it to Shervin.
Thank you, Afshin.
So now we saw how to generate a
clean image starting from noise.
And what we're seeing
in this equation
is that we need to repeat the
same procedure big T times.
And the thing is this big
T is usually quite large.
So it's the order of magnitude
of 1,000, for example,
in the original paper.
And let's say you
take the reference
point of existing image
generation models before that,
let's say VAEs or GANs, and
you compute the amount of time
it takes to generate
a single image, which
is the forward pass.
So you have to do
that now t times.
Let's say you had to do
it for 100 milliseconds.
Now it might take the
order of magnitude
of minutes, which is not great.
So one comment that we
have out of all of this
is that we want to bring the
computational burden down
at inference time.
So what can we do
to make that happen?
So I will first
show the equation
that Afshin has shown, linking
the generation process from step
t, which is a denoiser image,
to step t minus 1, which
is the slightly
cleaner image, which
was defined by that generation
process written on the slides.
And we're going to try to see
how to make these steps shorter.
So what can we do?
One strategy could be
to try to skip steps.
And the first thought
that comes to mind
is to write down
equations and see
if we can link a lower
step to a higher one
and see if we can make a
connection between the two
without going through
each of the steps.
So let's start by writing
down the same equation
for step t minus 1, and
then t minus 2, and so on.
And you come up with a
relationship linking a lower
step that you index by some
other sequence of numbers
that you call tau I, which is
a sequence of numbers between 0
and big T, where the gap
between consecutive numbers
is bigger than 1
potentially, and you end up
with a relationship that
involves step number tau I,
which is the larger step number,
and some sum over some numbers
and some sampled noise.
And as you can see,
it hasn't brought us
very far because you still have
quite a bit of model evaluations
to make, which is exactly the
gap between the two steps.
So that didn't work.
What can we do next?
So let's just keep that
sequence of numbers
that represents sequences of
steps that skip some in between.
One thing we could do is
try to guess a formula that
links two different steps.
And I'm showing you one
proposal of such a formula.
And I'm not going to
derive it, but just
going to verify that this makes
sense for two consecutive steps.
So if you say tau I is
step t, and tau I minus 1
is step t minus 1, when you
replace the numbers in there,
you will find again the
relationship between step
t minus 1 and t.
And so let's suppose you
use such a relationship
to link two different steps.
Then what you
realize in practice
is that as the amount
of stochasticity
that you have within
steps increases,
then your quality is
going to get worse
as a function of the step size.
So did that make sense.
So by the way, the density
of formulas in this last part
is slightly higher than
in the previous parts.
And the goal here is
more to get the intuition
of skipping steps and seeing
how it works more than looking
like at each formula separately.
So does that make sense so far?
OK, great.
So now we have
tried to skip steps
and we have found a relationship
that could link the two.
But we see that the
quality is not great
when you take large step sizes.
So what you're
trying to do now is
trying to do this
large step skipping,
but avoid that level of
stochasticity between steps.
So in order to do so we go
back to the drawing board
and look at the
derivation of the loss
function that you had
in the case of DDPM.
And one thing we realize
is that the a key part
to get to the formulation
of the DDPM loss
was the marginal
q of xt given x0.
And we realize that when we do
modeling choices that reproduces
that relationship on q, then
you can have a model that
is based on the same loss.
So this is one observation.
So the problem
statement comes back
to finding such a
q that reproduces
these marginal probabilities.
So with the same
x of xt given x0.
And the second constraint
that we want to put ourselves
is to have a generation
process that forgoes
of that stochasticity
term in order
to try to see if we can
mitigate the fact that quality
of generation gets worse.
This is the problem statement.
I'm going to write this down
in more mathematical terms.
So we want to find a familiar
function, let's say q sigma--
and I'm going to say
what sigma is very soon
and motivates why we are talking
about the family function here--
such that we match the
marginals with respect
to the DDPM forward process.
And the second
condition where I said
that we don't want any
stochasticity between two
generation steps is
translated by the fact
that we want p theta of the
least noisy image, given
the noisy image to
be deterministic,
meaning that once you have
xt, then your generation
process gives you xt minus
1 as a one to one mapping,
so there is no more noise term.
Does everyone agree on that?
So I'm going to throw
at you a formula
and verify that this works.
So this formula is
parameterized by a parameter
that is called sigma here
that is a hyperparameter.
And by reasoning with
the process of induction,
we can verify that the
marginals q sigma of xt given x0
matches the ones that we
had in the case of DDPM.
And when you set
sigma to 0, you can
see that this term becomes
just a mean with 0 variance.
So you can link xt minus 1
to xt with no stochasticity.
OK, great.
And so this state
of mind and coming
to the realization that you have
such a family of functions that
verify that, and the fact that
this is attractive to seek
is part of this
DDIM paper, where
the only term that changes with
respect to the title of DDPM
is this P, probabilistic,
to I, implicit.
So the probabilistic part
of DPM translated the facts
that when you generated a
clean image out of noise,
you had this probabilistic
nature between two steps.
But in this DDIM
formulation where
you don't have stochasticity at
the generation step between two
consecutive steps,
the stochastic part
only comes when you
sample your initial noise.
So your xT.
And this is why we call the
diffusion process implicit
because the probabilistic
part is not something
that you see between
consecutive steps,
but rather sets at the beginning
of the generation process.
So I think there was a
question at the very beginning
on why don't you start at
the same point every time.
So if you were to
do that, then DDIM
wouldn't have
worked because once
you set your initial
point of noise,
then you determine
deterministically your n image.
And then in this case, one thing
we can do is, at each step t,
we can approximate our belief
of what the clean image could
look like.
So if you remember, the marginal
distribution q of xt given x0
gives you a relationship
between xt, x0, and the noise.
And if you rearrange
the terms, then you
can approximate
x0 at every step.
This is just the rearrangement
of terms that proves that.
And then you can plug-in
that approximation of x0
into the formula that
we had just before
to determine xt minus 1 by
weighting this term accordingly
and adding to it
adequate noise weighted
by the right coefficient
at step t minus 1.
And as you can
notice here, there
is no added stochasticity
by construction
of this family of
forward processes
Q sigma when sigma equals 0,
which is the property that we
were after here.
So does that make sense so far?
So the question is where's
the skipping steps here.
We have not skipped
any steps so far.
We're just constructing
the generation process.
OK, great.
So if you recall, you had
these DDPM generation process
that you had that
did not skip steps.
So you had to go
one step at a time.
And now you can adapt the
formula that we saw from step t
to step t minus 1.
But now between these
schedule of steps
tau I's where at
step tau I minus 1,
you predict your best guess at
what the clean image x0 is based
on your step tau I, and you
approximate the noise that you
need to remove.
And you weigh each of
these terms at the step
tau I minus 1, which is
how you get this formula.
And here, we define
some concepts.
So when I talked about
the sequence of steps
tau I's, so the length
of that sequence is s.
So we call it s.
And t over s is the
effective speedup.
So instead of spending t steps
to generate a new sample,
you spend s steps.
And with that in mind,
the value for the speedup
that people typically
take is between 10 to 100.
And as you can guess, it
doesn't come for free.
So it's a trade off between
speed and actual quality
that you get in the end.
And the actual values
that people take
are more on the order of
magnitude of 10 to 50.
And here, I'm showing
what the authors
showed in one of their
experiments, the evolution
of one metric.
So here, FID means Fréchet
Inception Distance,
which is a metric that
we'll cover in lecture 7
when we'll talk
about evaluations.
So now I'm not going
to cover it in detail.
Just going to tell you
that it translates how
the generated images look like.
And so the absolute values
don't necessarily mean much.
But we can see the
impact on quality
based on relative differences.
And you can see that you can
speed up the process by taking s
of size such that at that
20x, you're not too far from
the baseline of not
skipping steps at all.
So the discussion
here is so we realized
that when you skipped steps,
the stochasticity that you
had between two consecutive
steps that the generation
process turned out to generate
worse estimates of what a lower
step would be, which is why
removing it is better here.
So here, we don't
show the comparison
with methods that do not
remove the stochasticity,
but the paper goes at
length into showing
that when you do
have stochasticity,
the results are much worse.
So if I had to summarize the
thought process that we went
through, we looked
at the DDPM loss,
we looked at the
core ingredients
of what got us there,
which was q of xt given x0.
We chose q sigma that verified
the same relationship.
And we made q sigma such
that it could be made--
so we could have a
generation process p
theta that is deterministic.
And once we had this
deterministic generation
process, so we call it DDIM.
And then we skip steps,
and we get the transition
from a generation process that
needs to go through T steps
to one that only needs to
go through S steps, which
is what we got in the end.
And with that, thank you
very much for your attention
and have a great weekend.